you'll have no clue what you're doing
was dead the science fiction movie
Midnight Special
isn't director Jeff Nichols firstly in
fact it's his fourth and in each one
Nichols has taken on a specific set of
challenges
all in the interest of prepping for ever
bigger movies in 2007 it was shotguns
stories Nichols debut the lesson
frugality he wrote what he knew feuding
brothers in rural Arkansas anything
happens to one of my brothers don't come
after all in the script is lean
he shot mostly with daylight to save on
production costs next was take shelter
about a father played by Nichols regular
Michael Shannon you trying to protect
his family from a maybe apocalypse
lessons right a strong female lead and
make cheap visual effects look
convincing
are you okay yeah I'm fine
it's been here a while nickels big
breakthrough was arguably 2012 mud the
lessons here land big-name stars never
said your name mud and gommi mud that's
Matthew McConaughey and Reese
Witherspoon as his ex can spend the rest
of my life running away with him and
learning to use a Steadicam in a classic
and hard to operate tool to show dynamic
cinematic which brings us to this year's
midnight special time the story of a
father and his super-powered son on the
run across the American South the
lessons here work with cross-cutting an
editing technique familiar to action
fans and settle into a studio where
people know how to get a movie in front
of a wider audience okay that's how you
get a hit